man who was in the Expendables trilogy a
photograph from which is on the front
cover of the train like an action hero
be fit forever book by Dolph Lundgren
good to see you sir how are you pleasure
yeah good to see you too you bet
so when you have somebody walk up to you
and say something to you about your
career do you still get you which one do
you get the most Dolph um well mostly
rocky I guess some of the younger kids
Expendables okay son Master so do
universe yeah funny enough that's kind
of coming back they're rebooting that as
well he man and all that stuff right
yeah so it varies there's the Punisher
of course there's been another three or
four since I did it I haven't seen any
of them but I hear they're pretty good
right so which is your favorite my
favorite yeah um well no I
I mean rocky 4 has kind of a good a good
piece of my heart because I was a kid
and I it was my first film you know I
met Stallone and by other people and em
hmm you know Carl Weathers unfortunately
what happened to him you know I didn't
write the script but so it's kind of
interesting that I'm back now after 33
years believe it or not to do this role
again it's kind of weird I never thought
I'd do it again you know did you're
doing Drago
yeah that's right no I don't want to I
don't want to have any spoiler alerts
yet on this front
Dolph but has your grasp of the English
language as a character expanded but
from those six lines in the first one
yeah I think it's for lunch in Russian
and one two in English well actually we
do have the breakdown on that front if
you don't which we might we're gonna put
a pin in that and get to it again later
but yeah so there there you are you just
put out a tweet of you in front of
Michael B Jordan a photograph oh that's
the Stallone's tweet yeah I don't tweet
you know it's no kidding no real men
don't tweet stick to Facebook okay I
like that
no that's what lets me and Michael be
yeah yeah you is back in from the 80s
and Michael B Jordan in Stallone right
there in the middle yeah but no he's
gonna have to fight my son in the new
picture
Manian boxer big guy 64 245 so I'm kind
of the the father slash trainer and
Stallone trains in a Rocky Balboa trains
yeah that'll be so but I think we'll end
up in a little I'm sure we get it on a
little bit me a slob well it looks like
you can still go a few rounds yeah I
think so how many how many rounds could
you give me right now uh I could do a
few yeah what do you mean like boxing or
kickboxing no I mean have you ever tried
anything no I did I did karate
full-contact karate when I was younger
and I was here at Payne champ back in
the day so I did ok bright but no I
haven't tried to MMA and they're tough
guys you know they're you know I I'm
impressed by some of those guys you know
it's a tough game I probably would have
done that if I was if I was young now so
if there was an octagon back in the
eighties you would have gotten in it
most probably just stupid enough to try
it yeah I think so stupid enough you're
a chemical engineer are you not what is
your what is your IQ dawg oh I don't
know come on it was pretty high before
all those punches in Rocky Ford I lost
15th round doesn't like took it out of
me but no I had a Fulbright scholarship
and I came over here to study
engineering when I was younger you know
and but I'd done some acting as a young
kid so I kind of when I came to New York
City and I was I ran into Andy World a
few people back in the day Michael
Jackson threw my girlfriend Grace Jones
at the time and I said I'm an actor yeah
yeah very quite young lady and I I
decided to become an actor and you know
within six months I was in this
auditioning process for this boxing
movie which turned out to be a rocky
picture and you know then I moved out
here and this is so you know the rest
kind of well sixty movies later well
before before we get into all that
give me your Michael Jackson story which
accent you actually it was at the 25th
Motown 25th anniversary which you see
sometimes on advertise you can buy the
DVD he did the moonwalk the first time
and I was there that that night that was
a kid you know it's about maybe 20
you know always said about 27 maybe was
fresh from Sweden fresh from Sweden yeah
from Australia from Australia because I
had a scholarship to Australia as well
to Sydney so went to school there met
grace then I met her again in Tokyo I
was there fighting and then I came to
New York and ran into him Andy Warhol
kind of put me in his magazine and a few
things happened quickly it was weird
my parents didn't get it they were like
what the hell's going on with his boy
you know but it all worked out it all
worked out pretty good you know pretty
well yeah so did you ever go to a Super
Bowl and you ever go to a World Series
Super Bowl did I have I been in Super
Bowl I don't think I've been to games
you know but I know of course you know
I'm going to Philly to shoot Creed - so
okay yeah there's a connection there you
know of course yeah so you're gonna go
to Philadelphia and do that whole thing
yeah okay like we started well when when
I'd like to take a 60-second break Dolph
and when we come back we'll talk a
little bit about your book again try and
like an action hero okay and and then it
is by the way nine lines that you had I
was looking for 7 in English - in
Russian we have them here I'd love to
see if you can try and remember as many
of the nine lines as you possibly can
[Laughter]
okay so I'm just giving you a heads up
you can jog your memory alright and in
the 60-second break
I'm gonna talk your book and then we'll
come back and we'll see how much you can
remember from Rocky for before you shoot
your Creed to Dolph Lundgren when we
come back here in the Rich Eisen show
[Music]
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
dolph lundgren
trained like an action hero be fit
forever here on the Rich Eisen show man
vs. food brings us our poll question
this is an interesting sponsor for her
poll question we've got a man who's in
shape right here we're talking about
Casey Webb being the the host of man vs.
food where he eats steaks in like 70
seconds in Billings Montana Monday
nights at 9:00 Eastern only on Travel
Channel ask Dolph long during the poll
question that we've been asking for all
three hours on the show Dolph who's got
the best action movie flat top action
movie flat oh how I long yourself or val
kilmer from Top Gun that's a tough one
we only ask those around here Dolph yeah
yeah it's an intellectual question that
I don't know [ __ ] the asteroid I
think I'll have to go for like I don't
want to say Ivan Drago so I have to say
how we long me now did you meet him in
an elevator he said that I did yeah I
think I did somewhere a long time ago
you know I met a lot of people when I
met Ali Mohammed I lead an elevator hold
on a second so if there was a there was
a Drago Muhammad Ali moment in an
elevator yeah there was there was he was
funny this is like way back like maybe
in the 80s and he was like jab me
immediately it was like yeah this is
what before when he was when he was more
elusive yeah sure so ya know he had seen
rocky four he'd seen it and I think that
was one of the fights I think it was at
the Hagler or it was Hagler showed sugar
and Leonard Leonard fight mattered
Hagler yeah so you were there I was
there I was actually doing some
commentary for I think it was ABC no I
was interviewing or I was interviewing
Leonard before the fight so I got to
know him and Hagler as well so I got to
know him a little bit yeah
and I ran into Muhammad Ali it was it
was a good great fight Don King
obviously you know III met him through
Stallone when I was training for rocky
for when you were living to visit when
you were living a try to sign me up yeah
okay so that I guess this just we got to
go the full thing James Brown you hang
out with James May up
yeah I was in my dressing room I was
doing Rocky for 27 year old didn't have
any assistance nothing you just mean my
boxing gloves and a glass of water or
something somebody knocked on the doors
one of his band members the guy with his
kind of sidekick uh-huh it says the
Reverend brown like to see you excuse me
Reverend I wanna see okay someone in
there and he was like talking to me for
a while and I think he knew about Grace
Jones so there was a connection there
are all conditions and you know
interesting guy
the funny thing was that you've never
done sing he never done playback before
and you have to do that song living in
America mm-hmm
and it was period pre-recorded and he
had to just mind to it and try to dance
but he didn't know how to do that
because he always just us live so
Stallone had to show him how to move and
it was interest alone was she got out of
the ring in his boxing boots he trying
to show him how to move but to say do
this James Brown was like frozen I think
he'd never been if he had been in the
big movie before I don't think he'd been
out get a little bit you know camera
showing no is that a big-time musician
had problems understanding how to
lip-sync which is a good thing that's
great and then milli vanilli happened
and the rest of the world changed I'm
saying right around the same time all
right
again before we get to this book I have
in my hands Dolph Lundgren the nine
lines yet not as Drago is Ivan Drago
we've had nine speaking lines two in
Russian seven in English let's just see
how many you can recall well
Dolph Lundgren the stage is yours Jesus
that was not one of them I wasn't you
did not say that okay because the
Communists religious you know if you
would join he thinks I want to do it in
character yeah a one of course was let
me say first I fought Apollo Creed and
that was you will lose when he hits my
love you others it will lose and his
feet come off the ground dink is the
Moses figure would have postponed the
fight and
then I say you will lose yes and if he
dies he dies was of course when he was
gonna die mhm
and then it's too and there's Stallone
in the ring right I must break you
that's three he is like a piece of iron
with some Russian won't catch Eliza or
something like that he is not a human
he's like a piece of iron which one of
the Russian lines correct you have four
of them he's got one more in Russian or
more in England what I win a pair of
boxing gloves yeah you get you get
trained like an action hero okay okay
Russian okay I had one more to the end
with some English yeah correct then come
on I think I run tit out something like
that no I don't know that's no you're
addressing the Politburo is a clue oh
yes I fight for me yes I fight for me
Libya Serbia I fight to win I fight for
myself I fight to win that's right dude
in the fat dude in a suit English okay
let's see if he does he dies you will
lose most miraculous break you to the
end we said that one right mmm-hmm I'll
give you I'll give you a hint the word
defeat or a form is in all three oh yes
I defeat old champion I know Sue and I
defeat real champion champion similar
defeat real champ yeah that's after he
dies right mm what else there's a little
speech there right that's what I got
I've got right before he if he dies he
that's true yeah Yeah right before if he
dies she does yeah the sooner defeat
real champ here I will give I've circled
the last two for you for you Drago I
cannot be defeated a defeat old man
maybe future
that's not bad
yes that five years in college
send that to Stallone he's done that to
Stallone and say you're ready for Creed
two right there okay so why did you uh
why did you decide to go for it and put
this one out
train like an action hero by Dolph
Lundgren Oh bookstores everywhere right
now where they are sold I just wanted to
tell my story about how I got into films
and how I get into training and why I
started doing physical training which is
I have a lot of problems when I was a
kid I was sick and I had a problem with
my dad it was kind of abusive and you
know I was kind of not you know I told
the story of why I ended up in the gym
the first place why I ended up being a
fighter and like a lot of men young men
who end up doing contact sports boxing
football if you checked with them I
think a lot of them would have a similar
background because you're trying to
prove something or you have some kind of
experience of the physical violence
maybe early in your life and that kind
of gives you a certain edge on the
playing field or in the ring and that's
what happened to me so I want to tell I
wanted to tell a story and how that led
into sports and highlight into finally
into movies and yeah and part of also
fighting that sort of pain and trauma
that I had and how I've managed to get
through that you know not just through
sports but also through working you know
with therapy and such and there so it's
kind of a kind of little story my story
but could also be inspirational I
thought to other people and especially
to men you know well it looks like again
you could go 12 rounds right now I'll
tell you that just sitting right next to
me so everybody should go check it out
train like an action hero by Dolph
Lundgren and inside there's all these
photographs if you going through the
actual reps and the actual workout
exercises that can actually get them to
look and train like an action hero well
it's also like you know there's no end I
mean once you want to if you want to be
fit you got to keep going and you know
at whether you're 25 or 35 or 50 or 60
or you can keep going for a long time so
well hey look any fan of the NFL knows
you see had hockey li out there he was
in Philadelphia
I'd just like you and your he was the
referee in the NFC Championship game
he's he's wind he he's ripped off if you
ever have you ever met Ed Hochuli you
know I think I've seen him but I haven't
met him there he is right there on our
screen right there what do you think of
that what do you what do you think of
those guns out right there it's good man
do you think he wears a shirt stat one
size too small to show it all for you
think that's real what do you think
tough you take a look at a VA
combination yeah he's a 67 year old man
at Harley but he looks good nice a good
good inspiration of people you know yeah
and that referee Mike Duffy from the
national championship game in the big 12
referee he's remember that what do you
think that bicep right there on first
down yeah no that's good that's good I
mean I look at guys like Stallone I'm
friends with him and he's 72 72 and you
know are not 70 and you know these guys
stay in shape you know and uh and
youngsters like me got somebody to look
OH I like it and plus again like the key
the key is the key is to wear us one
size too small I know you know we both
do that there look at that day as you
and salon right there did a little
commercial for Mexican beer that's uh is
that right - car D by steps by lifting
them right pretty much well that's gross
again check it out train like an action
here with Dolph Lundgren be fit forever
good to see you sir I got a little one
for you here sign it out red [ __ ] the
two ratio okay very good
this will not break me you're very very
impressive by the way you have to get
with those lines very impressive
yeah there weren't too many to remember